eine fahrt durch die wüste im süden von
nevada etwa eineinhalb stunden von las
vegas entfernt
die sonne geht gerade unter und wenn die
dunkelheit hereinbricht beginnt für
michael donath die arbeit seit einigen
jahren führt er weltraum und ufo
begeisterte haus in die nacht um den
himmel nach außerirdischem leben
abzusuchen und dass es dieses gibt steht
für ihn außer frage
wir haben rund 900 raumschiffe die die
ganze zeit um die erde fliegen
insgesamt sind es 1200 raumschiffe also
müssen da auch jetzt welche seien die
jederzeit über uns sind so eine geplante
wüstentour hat michael an diesem abend
abgesagt wollten hatten tagsüber die
sicht versperrt nicht etwa gewöhnliche
wolken sagt michael sondern chemtrails
nanopartikel die von flugzeugen
versprüht werden die künstliche wolken
erzeugen
da kann man nicht durchschauen auch
nicht mit fortschrittlichen
nachtsichtgerät
doch dann verziehen sich die wolken
michael und sein assistent können ihre
speziellen ferngläser doch noch aus
ihren koffern holen michael der selbst
pilot ist und früher als ingenieur mit
raketensystemen zu tun hatte ist hier
voll in seinem element
gerade als er uns erklärt dass
raumschiffe einige hundert kilometer
über der erde das sonnenlicht
reflektieren und deswegen gut zu
erkennen sind
wir haben ja 1 kumpel genau hier kannst
du sehen dass es einst der shuttle
schiffe 1 das fracht und passagiere zu
den sieben raumstationen bringt die wir
da oben haben von denen die meisten
leute nichts wissen
der blick ins weltall faszinierend und
voller geheimnisse und mit immer neuen
theorien dass dort zwischen den kometen
satelliten und flugzeugen noch anderes
leben sein muss sowie michael auf sedo
nah sind sie einige kilometer weiter
ebenfalls davon überzeugt auf der ufo
mega konferenz in loughlin nevada
während die gäste im erdgeschoss eines
casino hotels irdischen verlockungen
erliegen diskutieren die konferenz
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer eine
etage höher über geheime raumschiffe
oder paranormal i tät ernsthaft versteht
sich grüne alien kostüme trägt hier
deswegen niemand spirituelle übungen die
den geist erweitern sollen sind hier
jedoch selbstverständlich ebenso wie die
schilderungen von hinten harrison der
erzählt wie er nach eigenen angaben
mehrfach von aliens vor dem tod gerettet
wurde
ich bin in einem kranken ich verlasse
meinen körper weil ich die schmerzen
nicht aushalten kann
ich bin verletzt und als nächstes bin
ich in einer anderen umgebung
das könnte auf einem raumschiff gewesen
sein ich weiß nicht aber ich war in
einem anderen op saal und drei
außerirdische über mir die mich
anschauen
die man knie bearbeiten und ein paar
tage später war ich geheilt und ich
konnte aus dem krankenhaus ob er sich
das vielleicht nur eingebildet hat da
ist sich hinten harrison selbst nicht
ganz sicher aber er sieht es als teil
seiner persönlichkeit scherzhaft sagt er
dass jemand auch mal sein smartphone
mitnehmen könne wenn er aliens trifft
für fotos bob brown organisiert die
einwöchige konferenz jedes jahr schon
als neunjähriger begann er sich mit ufos
und aliens auseinanderzusetzen
als wir ihn fragen was ihn an all dem so
fasziniert reagiert er fast ungehalten
machen sie witze ist das universum
unendlich jeder wird sagen es ist
unendlich
je weiter wir wissenschaftlich nach
draußen schauen um so mehr universum
gibt es was ist das einzig mögliche ziel
eines unendlichen universums es ist
einfach unendliches leben
dass die us regierung geheimdienste und
pentagon beauftragt hat ihr wissen über
ufos und aliens öffentlich zu teilen
sorgt nicht nur bei ufo fans für
aufregung in den usa ist das thema
überall präsent vor allem nachdem diese
aufnahmen veröffentlicht wurden die
piloten sichteten bei trainingsflügen
immer wieder unbekannte flugobjekte wir
haben solche objekte gesehen sie haben
sich schnell bewegt als wir näher kam
wirkte es so als wollten sie uns
ausweichen und dann war da noch ex
präsident barack obama der den hype mit
befeuerte und in einer talkshow zwar
keine details ausplauderte aber er gab
zu dass es bilder und aufzeichnungen
über objekte am himmel gibt von denen
wir nicht genau wissen was sie sind
inzwischen sind erste details des ufo
reports durchgesickert die schon
andeuten das bahnbrechende erkenntnisse
nicht zu erwarten sind offenbar gibt es
bei den sichtungen keine hinweise auf
außerirdische aber eben auch keine
erklärung was da zu sehen ist das treibt
neue blüten
es könnte sich vielleicht um hightech
fremder staaten handeln mancher
wissenschaftler oder ufo skeptiker mahnt
deswegen zur besonnenheit
die leute versuchen zu sagen so sind das
chinesische drohen
ist das eine art russisches raumschiff
ist das alien technik eine art
natürliches phänomen
die realität ist dass jeder einzelne
dieser fälle individuell betrachtet
werden wir einzeln herausfinden können
was es sein könnte
und viele der fälle haben tatsächlich
sehr vernünftige erklärung
besonders die für die wir video beweise
haben die an die öffentlichkeit gelangt
sind wetterphänomene optische
täuschungen am ende wären es also wieder
sehr irdische erklärungen und nicht
fremder besuch aus dem all
bei unserem dreh in der wüste von nevada
will michael auf zu dohna mindestens
sechs raumschiffe am nachthimmel
entdeckt haben seine ganz persönliche
sicht auf diese dinge dürfte auch der
uhu report der us regierung kaum
erschüttern